so my name is Henry I'm a data scientist
at citizen analytics and today I'm gonna
be talking about measuring model
fairness before we get started a quick
outline of where we're headed I'm gonna
start by motivating the problem a little
bit and here I don't mean just the
problem of model fairness but I mean the
problem of why you should think
carefully about how you go about
measuring model fairness it's actually
kind of a slippery tricky subject so
next I'm going to talk about some
different subtleties that show up when
you set out to do this when you set out
to measure the fairness of a models
predictions and give you some points to
think about when you're doing this
yourself like different things to look
out for and ways to think about this
question and then finally I'm gonna wrap
things up with a case study that we did
using some real-world data from some of
our consulting engagements at civis that
shows how these these subtleties can
crop up when you're trying to measure
the fairness of a model in a real-world
setting with real world data so that's
where we're headed to start off with I
think there is a pretty broad consensus
at this point that machine learning
models can have a big impact on people's
lives so credit scoring models determine
whether you can get a loan to buy house
advertising models determine what kind
of job opportunities you get exposed to
through job ads or what kind of credit
products or credit terms you get exposed
to through credit offering
advertisements and machine learning
models can even affect things like how
long you spend in jail waiting for
parole so this is a this is common
knowledge now people are pretty aware of
the fact that these machine learning
models have large impacts and that's
given rise to a similarly broad concern
about how you go about making sure that
these models are fair making sure that
these models aren't unfairly
discriminating against people
unfortunately that's where the consensus
ends because figuring out how to answer
this question and model fairness is is
slippery and contentious
and this example here about parole and
models determining how long you spend in
jail is actually very illustrative so
quick show of hands how many of you are
familiar with the controversy around the
compass recidivism model people part of
that handful okay so the story here for
those of you who are unfamiliar is that
ProPublica which is an independent
investigative journalism outfit did an
investigation into this model called
compass that's used to predict
recidivism so predict the likelihood
that people in prison will recommit
crimes once they are released so this is
a model that has apparently used pretty
widely across the country in informing
decisions about parole like this model
spits out a likelihood that someone will
go on to commit more crimes after
they're released and that score informs
decisions about when people get released
on parole so ProPublica got some data
about this model and about its
predictions and analyzed it and came to
the conclusion that this model was
unfairly biased against black people to
support that conclusion they looked at
the ways in which the model failed so
looked at errors in the models
predictions and what they found was that
the the failure rates were different for
people of different races so if you look
at false positives people who are
labeled high-risk but end up not
reoffending that error rate is about 24%
for white defendants and about 45% for
black defendants similarly if you look
at the false negatives people who the
model label has a low risk of recidivism
of having a low risk of recidivism but
that did actually go on to reoffended
error rate is about 48% for white people
and 28% for black people so on the basis
of this analysis ProPublica wrote a
report and said this compass model that
is widely used across the country in
making
all decisions is biased against black
people so that's one half of the story
after this report came out North Point
which is the company that makes this
compass model and sells the product
responded by saying that the model was
not unfair because it had several
similar overall performance for both
white people and black people and to
prove that they looked at the the AUC so
this is a kind of a general measure of
the quality of a classifier that tells
you how much better it's doing the
random and they found that overall the
this overall accuracy was the same we're
very similar for white people and for
black people and similarly if you just
look at the total accuracy like the
number of predictions it got right over
the total number of predictions it made
that number is also similar for both
white defendants and black defendants so
but on the basis of this North Point
said no our model actually is fair so
the question we're left with is how do
you decide which measure of fairness is
appropriate you might instinctively say
well let's just make sure these are both
satisfied like make sure the errors are
balanced and that also the overall
accuracy is balanced unfortunately in
almost all cases that is mathematically
impossible so once this controversy came
out around the compass model some
researchers went and showed that except
in like very contrived cases except in
for example the case where you have
totally perfect predictions across the
board that it's mathematically
impossible to satisfy both of these
decisions both of these descriptions of
fairness so the question for us and the
question I'm going to talk about in the
rest of the talk is how should you think
about how to define fairness in the
context of the model that you're
building or the problem that you're
working on and this is there are kind of
a number of studies to this question so
next I'm going to walk through the three
of these subtleties three points for you
to think about when you go to make this
kind of classification model that might
affect somebody's life
the first subtlety is that different
groups can have different ground truth
positive rates so there can legitimately
be differences between the rates of the
positive class like the number of ones
your model spits out versus the number
of zeros in between different groups so
an example I like to use here is suppose
you were building a classifier that was
trying to predict diagnosis of breast
cancer according to these statistics
women get breast cancer about two orders
of magnitude more frequently than men do
something like 12% vs. 0.1%
so there are very legitimate differences
in the ground truth positive rates for
this problem between genders the issue
is that certain fairness metrics make
assumptions about the balance of ground
truth positive rates so there's one
metric called disparate impact this is
also sometimes called statistical parity
and this metric assumes that the ground
truth positive rates are balanced
between the two classes are equal
between the two classes the way this
metric is defined is you just look at
the probability of a positive
classification for both groups and then
take the ratio of that but you can see
how that implies that the ground truth
positive rates would have to be the same
for the two groups for this metric to be
meaningful in our breast cancer case
we're gonna fail this test dramatically
because there's two orders of magnitude
difference between the classification
rate but still this is a popular metric
because it's the only one that is
referenced in u.s. case law so there's a
like a historical precedent for using
this as a metric of fairness so that's
that's one subtle to either legitimate
differences in ground truth positive
rates another subtlety is that you don't
actually know what the ground truth is
you only have data and your data is a
biased representation of what the ground
truth is your data is not the truth it's
some some biased approximation of the
truth
there's a famous quote by the
statistician George box who said that
all models are wrong but some models are
useful I think in this context you can
adapt that you all datasets are biased
but some datasets are useful so you can
still use these data to fit models but
you have to think carefully about how
your data is not reflective of the real
world there are a couple different types
of bias that can show up in your data
and I think it's helpful to think about
kind of the different types because that
can inform how you think about measuring
fairness so one of these types of bias
is what I call label bias and this is
when a protected attribute so something
like gender or race or age affects the
way labels are assigned within your data
set so I have here a quote from a paper
that was investigating school discipline
and I think I like elementary school or
middle school and the authors found that
students from African American and
Latino families were more likely than
students from white families to be
suspended for the same types of problem
behavior so if you have a data set like
this and you set out to build a model
that predicts like student will have
problem behavior but the label that
you're using is student has been
suspended then you're operating with
label bias because different groups are
getting assigned labels differently
within your model and it's not an
accurate reflection of actual student
problem behavior this is a problem
because there are also several fairness
metrics which are based on the agreement
between your models predictions and the
labels in your training data but if
you're optimizing for agreement with
labels and those labels are themselves
biased all you're doing is perpetuating
the bias that generated those labels in
the first place here a popular metric is
called equal Apple opportunity and this
is comparing quote true positive rates
with your models predictions so looking
at the probability that a given group
will be classified as a one classified
as a positive
given that their original training label
was positive and comparing that rate
between groups there's also a similar
one called equal miss opportunity which
compares true negative rates but here
again the problem is this metric this
fairness thing that you're using to
determine whether or not your models
predictions are fair it's based on
agreement with the labels and if the
labels themselves are biased then you're
not actually addressing the fairness
question another way your data can be
biased is if the sampling process that
generated your data is different between
groups so the idea here is you know
you'll have some process out in the
world which is generating the data that
you're using to train your model and if
that process operates differently for
different groups of people then that's
going to bias the data that you're using
to train your model as well the example
I have here is a quote from an analysis
out of Andrew gell-mann's group of the
stop and frisk policy from the New York
Police Department and in their analysis
they found that people of African and
Hispanic descent were stopped more
frequently than white people even after
controlling for Geographic variation and
estimates of crime participation so if
you're working with a dataset based on
like results from stop and frisk stops
then it's likely that that dataset has
sampled bias because the process by
which people are getting put into the
data set operates differently for
different groups of people this is also
a problem because some metrics compare
ratios of classifications within groups
so I'm going to go back to disparate
impact here we talked about how this is
the kind of the ratio of the positive
classifications for two groups but
either the numerator or the denominator
is kind of like the ratio within a
particular group of different outcomes
so it's like the probability of a
positive classification within a
particular group but if you're sampling
groups differently if you're sampling
everyone in one particular group but
only high-risk individuals and another
particular
you're gonna throw off that ratio and
again compromise the utility of this
particular metric when you're trying to
assess fairness so the last subtlety is
that the consequences of your model
matter if you're making a model that is
punitive the consequences of your models
decisions are negative you're handing
out a punishment that I could see making
a case for caring more about false
positives you care about not punishing
innocent people based on the output of
your model similarly if your model is
assistive like it's handing out
something good handing out something
positive I could see you caring more
about false negatives not wasting your
resource or resources on people who
don't need the benefit that you're
handing out I'm not saying this is the
only way to think about punitive and
assistive models like I could see
compelling cases for other arguments
like caring about other outcomes but the
point is that you have to think
carefully about this question like you
have to think about what the
consequences of your model are and that
can inform what kind of errors matter to
you so the final takeaway from kind of
these three points these three
subtleties that I want to stress is that
we can't math our way out of thinking
about fairness like these these are
human questions with ethical
implications and you need some human
judgment to make an appropriate decision
about how you define fairness in your
context and then how do you go about
measuring it I think historically there
was a temptation when machine learning
models first started being used to make
these decisions to say models are just
math and computers so they can't be
unfair and at this point that has been
pretty thoroughly debunked like that's I
think not a common opinion anymore but
there's a temptation to take the same
logic take the same reasoning and just
move it one step farther down the food
chain it's not the models are math so
they must be fair it's I'm gonna add a
little bit of extra math on top of my
model and then it'll be fair but you
can't just rely on the math you still
need a human person applying human
judgments
what makes your model fare so these are
kind of the subtleties of this question
of how you should think about measuring
the fairness of your models output next
I'm going to talk about kind of an
example case study experiment we did at
civis using some real-world data from
one of our consulting engagements to
show how these kind of subtleties and
complications can manifest when you're
doing this with real data that has like
real complicated correlations and lots
of complicated causal pathways within it
so to start off with we're going to work
with a data set from one of our
consulting engagements the features here
are largely demographics and like
socio-economic type indicators and the
outcome is the probability that a person
will sign up for the services of a state
agency and what we're going to look at
is we're going to try to assess racial
bias so we're gonna look at modelled
outcomes for white people versus black
people and to do that we're gonna kind
of make two fake worlds so in one of
these worlds we're going to artificially
balance ground truth so remember that
was the first subtlety that you have to
think about when you're doing this kind
of exercises is ground truth balance
between the different classes that I
care about here we're making a
hypothetical world where ground truth is
totally balanced and we do that by
taking only the white people in the
original data set and then randomly
reassigning race labels so at this point
race is totally uncorrelated with
outcome our ground truth is totally
totally balanced that's one hypothetical
world the other hypothetical world is
where we use the original imbalance data
set so in the raw data white people were
dramatically more likely to sign up for
the services of this agency and so we
use that as another hypothetical world
where we're saying that's ground truth
and ground truth is imbalanced so that's
our foundation these two different
worlds next we're going to introduce
known amounts of these different types
of bias
so remember subtlety number two was your
data is not the truth
it's a biased representation of the
truth and there's two different ways it
can be biased or there's lots of ways
but in this case we're talking about two
different ways it can be biased one of
these is with sample bias so in these
two different worlds we then sampled
from the sub population differentially
based on score thresholds and race
assignments so to introduce sample bias
we preferentially sampled white people
with high scores and avoided our sampled
at a lower rate white people with low
scores and then sampled black people
uniformly so this is injecting some
known sample bias into these datasets
that we're gonna use to train some
models in a similar fashion we injected
some known label bias so remember our
original original labels are
probabilities that you'll sign up for
this agency service we converted those
probabilities into binary labels but
used a different threshold for white
people and for black people so we used a
low threshold for white people and a
high threshold for black people so using
this we can start with like different
ground true so that we know different
hypothetical worlds inject these
different types of bias train a model on
the resulting data set and then apply
these different fairness metrics to the
outcome of to the predictions of those
models to see how well these different
metrics do in these different
hypothetical worlds with different types
of bias present in our training data so
that's that's the set up of the
experiment the two metrics that I'm
going to talk about here are disparate
impact and equal opportunities those are
the ones I mentioned previously that are
kind of generally popular in the
literature and you hear people talk
about in the actual paper we have a
paper written up and post on the archive
you address a couple other metrics so if
you're interested I encourage you to go
look up the paper on the archive but
we're applying these two metrics to
those two hypothetical worlds and for
different situations where we either
have the no no bias
we've introduced different types of bias
and this is what the results look like
in the hypothetical world where ground
truth is balanced so on the Left we have
results for disparate impact this is the
ratio based comparison on the right we
have the results for equal opportunity
which is the difference based comparison
for difference for disparate impact
because it's a ratio values of 1
indicate no measured unfairness and for
equal opportunity values of zero because
it's a difference indicate no measured
unfairness so what you see here is in
this hypothetical world where ground
truth is balanced between the classes
these metrics work pretty well
like they don't detect any bias they
don't measure bias in the case where we
have not artificially introduced by us
but we when we artificially introduce
sample bias or label bias they start
detecting more bias and then when we
have both types of artificially injected
bias in our training data set the the
fairness metrics detect that is being
even worse than either independently so
so far so good when your ground truth is
balanced these metrics are performing
fairly well unfortunately the picture is
dramatically less rosy if you're in a
hypothetical world where ground truth is
not balanced between your classes so
this is the the same same measurement
disparate impact over here on the left
equal opportunity a value of 1 means no
measured unfairness over here a value of
0 means no measured unfairness over here
and we can see that in the unbalanced
ground truth case both of these metrics
are measuring dramatic unfairness even
when we haven't injected bias into our
data and even worse it's even worse when
you look at label bias in particular
because if you compare the case where we
haven't injected any bias into our
training data to the case where we've
actually deliberately injected label
bias both of these metrics give you more
or less the same result and if you think
about it that kind of makes sense
because label bias is about labels being
assigned differently between groups
but if ground truth is different
legitimately between groups you're
already going to have differences in
labels assigned between groups so it's
especially hard to detect this kind of
bias so oh and here's a link to the
white paper here I describe these two
metrics therefore more in the paper and
also a slightly more in-depth treatment
of kind of the reasoning appetite behind
the experimental setup and this framing
so if you're interested I encourage you
to go check that out so that's kind of
the story so what should we do about it
well there's not really a
one-size-fits-all solution other than
think hard about your inputs and outputs
think hard about what's going into your
model think hard about the process that
generated your data think hard about the
kind of the ground truth that you're
trying to model in the first place and
how well your your label your dependent
variable in your training data
approximates the thing that you actually
care about modeling think about what's
going into your model and think about
what's coming out of your model think
about where your predictions are going
what kind of effects what kinds of
consequences stem from the decisions
made by this model that you have these
metrics that we talked about today can
help along with other metrics there's
there's kind of quite a variety of
different metrics people have proposed
for measuring fairness but you have to
use them carefully you have to think
about these questions these subtleties
of what this fair actually mean in the
context of the model that I'm building
right here if you do have good answers
to those questions there are also
methods in the literature that will help
you train models that automatically
respect some of these metrics so you can
kind of include them in your objective
function in some sense but again you
really have to know you really have to
be certain that one of these metrics
matches what fairness really means in
the context of your problem and what
you're talking about
use a diverse team to create these
models and think about these questions
throughout this talk I've tried to
emphasize that it's really a question of
human judgment but if
everyone on your team thinks about
things in exactly the same way then
you're not going to have good coverage
on the kinds of issues the kinds of
things that you need to be thinking
about when you're assessing these
ethical questions of fairness so you
know have a diverse team when you're
doing this really human work of thinking
about what fairness means in the context
of your model and then finally just to
repeat like think about your data
think about your predictions think about
the effects that everything has I'll
leave you with this quote from Cathy
O'Neill's book weapons of mass
destruction about how this is really a
human moral question that your data is
not the truth and even if it were the
truth is it the kind of truth that you
want to see in the world like that's
that's a really human question and we
can't math our way out of having to use
human judgment to answer it thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much really important and
well delivered talk um am i
understanding correctly that there's
another possible scenario where you have
both label and sample bias but they
operate in opposite directions and can
come out showing no bias at all yeah
that could totally happen
all right guitar this is a tough topic
let's say you create a model that it's
unbiased when it comes to arresting
between demographic it's right now it's
is because the police officers choose
different like they they sample
differently and let's say you deploy its
model and now it chooses now it's
unbiased is great but it's different
from the real world now like um the
police officers would say that's not how
we work that's that we prefer doing this
bias thing like how do you square that
reach yeah that's that's a good question
and it's a hard question so I point to
the end of Kathy O'Neal's quote where
sometimes it means putting fairness
ahead of profit like if just optimizing
for like the performance metric of your
model is the only objective function
that you're considering then I agree
that this is a hard to apply in that
kind of cast case I think the point I'm
arguing for is that it shouldn't be the
only thing in your objective function
does that answer your question
kind of yeah it's it's an ethical
question that I don't have like a hard
and fast answer to ok be sure to let you
all in time so we can get lunch any more
questions
all right thanks Harriet
you